the fact that the quietness and The
Emptiness in your home when you don't
have your spouse or your children is
deafening you have to really get
comfortable with being alone and it's
very uncomfortable or or here this could
be a better one I made a mistake I've
never hear these women say that they
[__] up what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to my reaction series today I'm
going to be reacting to woman instantly
regrets divorcing her husband women
hitting the wall and um
I don't I wasn't prepared for that I
wasn't prepared for feeling that way
even when you're not together before we
continue from this video here is a
message from our sponsors it's crazy how
much of my personal information is out
there and I wonder if there is a way to
track or stop this data Brokers sell
your information to scammers spammers
and anyone else who may want to Target
you your full name email home address
health records your relatives it is all
out there that is why I have been using
Aura the sponsor of today's video Aura
shows me which data Brokers are selling
my information and automatically submit
opt out request for me cleaning up my
information not only helps reduce the
amount of spam I get but it also
protects me from hackers who can use
this information to help them access my
social media accounts bank accounts or
other sensitive information AA also does
so much more to protect me and my family
from online threats that I can't see
it's super easy to set up so I don't
have to download several different apps
to get things like anti virus VPN or
password management parental controls
identity theft Insurance and more I get
everything at one affordable price using
Aura is unbelievable how many data
Brokers I found were selling my personal
information online you may already have
one or two of these tools but not having
Aura is like locking the front door and
leaving the back door wide open Aura is
always on doing the hard work of keeping
me safe so I can focus on other tasks
with peace of mind I value my privacy
and I value yours you can go to
aa.com Pearl to start your twe free
trial also find the link in the
description welcome back family today we
will review some more crying divorced
women who just cannot seem to understand
that the grass isn't always greener on
the other side what's the one thing you
wish everyone around you knew about
getting divorced everyone always
prepares you that whenever you're going
through a divorce losing who filed who
filed lady hband or wife you go through
a grieving process grieving for the loss
of your marriage um the loss of your
hopes and dreams together um but one
thing that they really don't prepare you
for is the loss of a friend the loss of
your best friend I mean what did you
think was going to happen it's like
women ruin their whole families and
they're confused when they lose their
husband the person that you always just
wanted to tell you know tell your day
and to tell you know your small wins and
your small
victories and
um I don't I wasn't prepared for that I
wasn't prepared for feeling that way
even when you're not together and
haven't been together um just having
that
desire to have them as a friend again
just another day and another modern
woman making an Impulse decision to
divorce her husband without really
thinking about the consequences and I've
seen this I have had I have interviewed
over a thousand people on my show and I
have had so many chicks who divorced
their husbands for damn near no reason I
outgrew him I have heard that so many
times oh let me just ruin my family put
my kids at every statistical
disadvantage because I outgrew him and
really what's happening is social media
has ruined relationships women see men
on social media they think the grass is
greener on the other side and it's not
and a lot of times it's lonely with a
bunch of cats and that's why Kevin
Samuels would say to bye dog die alone I
bet that she was convinced that leaving
her husband was a good idea by listening
to some divorced Guru woman on the
internet talking about how divorce is
wonderful most women go to the internet
not for learning but to find someone
that will validate the idea that they
already had in their mind because deep
down that can that they are not doing
the right thing check it out is there
anyone out there in Tik Tock land that
can tell me
what you're supposed to do with your
life when you've been in a relationship
for 20 plus years with the same person
you have children you have you know
built a life stay stay that's what
they're going to say stay and then all
of a sudden that life is no longer what
why tell me why why is it no longer who
filed supposed to do with your life like
I I work I'm a I'm a registered nurse I
I have a so I have a career I guess um I
have nurses we've been telling you guys
about the nurses Hobbies I have
like I don't know a
house I have all the things that I guess
you need to live the life but I I don't
know how I don't like do you do you date
other people like do you do you sort of
like I just don't know I want to focus
on myself I want to be happy but see she
she's talking about what she wants and
that's what women do women just never
think about what their kids want what
their husband wants it's always me me me
what I want I want to I just I I want I
want I want to I want to heal from this
that's another thing I'm so tired of
hearing about healing I'm so tired of
hearing about healing what do you guys
need to heal from you know healing used
to be like an injury maybe war that used
to be trauma now it's all right all
right whole process that I've been in
but I also want to live life like I also
want to have fun I don't want it to be
all about being miserable and feeling
sad and and just going through the
motions of life because my relationship
my marriage broke down like I I just
don't want to do that anymore I want to
be happy I want to move on and I want to
just if you weren't happy in your
marriage you're not going to be happy
outside of it you're either a happy
person or you're not find joy in life
again I know that most of you just
wanted to jump on your screens when you
heard the infamous phrase I just want to
be happy trust me me too it's the same
story over and over and over again and
again and again it's all about me me me
me without even knowing what they really
want but then they get shocked when the
ex-husband move on with his life like in
our next clip my husband fell in love
with my best friend now ex-husband ex-
best friend but they fell in love it's
now been 4 years and I wanted to share a
very important lesson that I learned the
people that are meant to be in your life
will will be in your life nothing will
stop them from Simply being in your life
if it's so easy for wom aen we have no
friends the more I see this stuff I'm
like we have zero friends yeah went to
leave then they were never truly meant
to be with you long term anyways also I
see people begging people to stay in
their life you really want someone in
your life that you have to beg for no
thank you and if you're really fighting
for someone to stay don't you value and
respect yourself enough to just let them
go
I know that divorce is really hard and I
know that sitting in the loneliness is
really hard but it's way better than
begging and pleading for someone to see
your worth and your value you are worth
so much more than that and I hope you
see that so from one heartbreak to
another I see you and I love you it's
amazing how these women will always try
to play it cool as if they are not
jealous hurt and bitter when they see
their husbands Moving on but you can see
the anger and disappointment through her
just in case you want more affirmation
on how her life is miserable I went
through her page and here is one of her
latest video where she admit on how
miserable her life really is so there
are some crucial things that people
don't talk about after you go through
sometimes these women talk I'm like what
are you try to make a Hallmark movie you
see how like the music in the background
playing and everything the fact that the
quietness and The Emptiness in your home
when you don't have your spouse or your
children is staning you have to really
get comfortable with being alone and
it's very uncomfortable you could or or
here this could be a better one I made a
mistake I've never hear these women say
that they [__] up it's always I [__]
up because I was young I was not like
men in general some of you guys act like
women I won't even lie to you you'll be
like oh I messed up because of the it's
no but in general in general women it's
like it's never I just I messed up I was
wrong I'm sorry it's like this
rationalization like you don't think if
it's been 4 years in your house is empty
something's maybe not going right I
don't know realize that you are now the
center stage of all conversation in your
friend group because you're now living
this wild and fun life because you're no
longer attached to anybody and I don't
know about you but I spent a lot of my
time crying and eating pizza and
drinking wine in the bathtub oh but live
your best life girl single is glamorized
in today's society and people are saying
yes good for being single and you should
really tattoos nose ring enjoy it it's
so freeing when really lost your purpose
because you've been supporting this
person for x amount of years and
supporting their aspirations and and
their goals and their dreams and their
desires and you lost yourself along the
way so now you yeah it's beautiful you
get to find yourself and but it's hard
to sit in that and be like oh who the am
I so maybe be a little bit more gentle
on the single people in your life all
these strong independent happy Single
Living my best life women you see on the
internet have the same sad story behind
close doors they are all crying
miserable lonely depressed bitter and
angry women that's not fair that's not
fair that's is not fair my thing is if
you didn't want to be with him that's
fine I mean I don't advocate for it but
okay that that was your choice deal with
your choice but my question is why do
you care if you moved he moved on you
you didn't want him so if you didn't
want him why are you mad when he wants
someone else it doesn't make any sense
to lead more women astray so that they
can all be miserable because we know
that misery loves company and it's sad
that so many young women keep falling
for their lies I have a bonus clip for
you that shows the consequences of oh I
love him J James ston he's great
government incentivizing women to
divorce their husbands I do divorces for
people that you know a woman walks out
with2 $300 million he was an analyst at
Goldman Sachs who built a hedge fund and
then sold it and then used his trading
algorithm to build it up to $500 million
she was
hot that'll do it slept with him for a
while and then stopped and started
sleeping with other people and playing
tennis and having Botox and she's going
to get half like that's incredible like
do you know what he do to get that and
it's so funny women will take all the
credit like if you ask that woman she
built a man that's another thing I'm
tired of ladies ladies ladies cooking
cleaning and being supportive is not the
same thing as as building a man I mean
did you Mentor him
no did you invest in his business first
no did you pay for his education no okay
so shut up I mean you cook I mean so can
some chick for $12 an hour like it's
not you know it's not that hard anyways
yeah had all that guy for $200 million
are you kidding me like that's insane
that's incredible fellas as long as
these family laws are still in place you
going and that's the thing they want men
to be traditional but they always want
the men to do it first they don't want
Society to do it first and and the
unfortunate thing is men can't be
traditional in this Society it doesn't
work they literally cannot do it because
as long as you have a law as long as you
have a divorce law as an incentive
structure that pays women to leave I
mean how can men be traditional and
count on them staying so um let me know
what you guys think in the comments
leave a comment below like the video on
your way out make sure you subscribe to
the channel ring that notification Bell
and I'll talk to you next
time